all right Ben you have not shied away at
times from being very critical of
President Donald Trump let me ask you
specifically what do you think about his
Middle East policy so far I mean I think
his Middle East policies been quite good
I think that President Trump has
responded quite correctly to the
stupidity of the Obama policy that made
a run regional player by strengthening
the alliance between Saudi Arabia Jordan
Egypt and Israel and his move to make
Jerusalem the official capital of Israel
according to the United States is one
that will actually strengthen that
alliance not weaken it because it
actually takes the issue off the table
for discussion so I think that so far as
Middle Eastern policies been a hell of a
lot better than I thought it would be
when he was a weapon then that being
said do you believe there was a wise
decision for Trump to recognize
Jerusalem as Israel's capital at this
time even for him to say that the issue
of Jerusalem was quote off the table for
future negotiations it did lead to
violence here as you know in the Middle
East
and there does seem to be that there's
no clear policy moving forward I mean
there was no clear policy before so I'm
not really shocked that there is a clear
path there's no clear policy now I mean
the fact is you cannot negotiate with
people who want to murder you and the
Palestinian Authority's been offered
pieces of Jerusalem at least two times
in the last 15 years they've walked away
from the table both times so all of that
was was merely a ruse that they could
launch violence and complain about
Israeli intransigence and all the rest
of it the fact is that Israel is not
giving up the old city of Jerusalem when
a Hutu old man offered to
internationalize the Old City of
Jerusalem Mahmoud Abbas didn't even come
up with a counteroffer so I'm not sure
exactly what anyone expects from Israel
at this point I'm glad that Trump
doesn't expect anything from Israel on
this point either because it would be
stupid to do so so what do you make of
the State Department's decision though
to not say Jerusalem Israel on official
documents and maps that there's no
change in the passport policy on certain
avenues who was born in Jerusalem and
her passport is just a ruse alone not
Jerusalem Israel that's that's
ridiculous and insane and I would hope
that the Trump administration would do
something about that and just order in
the State Department as part of the
Trump administration now too I hope that
they would order the State Department to
simply start issuing those passports
making some past articles and comments
you've been vocal about supporting
population transfers you once wrote in
town
if Israel is to exist you must allow
Israel to transfer the Palestinians and
also Israeli Arabs from Judea Samaria
Gaza and even Israel proper you're
talking about the entire West Bank do
you still believe that and do you think
it's a practical solution no I wrote
that column actually back when I was 19
years old so that's not my current
position on the issue I've actually
denounced my own position yes you from
back when I was 19 what I've suggested
in my solution is that there is no
long-term solution other than security
and that security is going to be reached
simply by Israel annexing territory that
it feels that it needs to maintain for
its own security and then protecting
that area with its military there is no
long-term peace solution here because
again Israel is facing down an
implacable foe and deporting millions of
people from Judea and Samaria is not a
practical solution or moral one is that
either been Israel's current defense
minister very vocal about his support
for land swaps many politicians in fact
to advocate publicly for land swaps what
are your thoughts on land swaps do you
think it's a good idea moving forward
yeah I mean land swaps are a different
thing right there you're talking about
Israel giving up certain lands and in
less populated areas in favor of the
areas that Israel has already cultivated
and settled rather than talking about
making sure that efrat remains part of
Israel obviously and then giving up some
lands in another part of Israel to make
up for that I'm I don't see what's
implausible about that particularly but
I think that the entire process right
now is implausible the idea of giving up
one inch of land to a terrorist regime
which is what the Palestinian Authority
is it seems patently insane to me
what would you tell President Trump
right now if he's watching right now I
mean he said Jerusalem is Israel's
capital he said that he started the
process of moving the embassy but what's
specifically what you tell him he needs
to do right now well I mean I would move
the embassy I mean I'm not just saying
the movie embassy I mean like actually
rent a room and move the embassy there
it's not as though you need a huge space
in order to make this happen they should
they should physically move it because I
fear that what will happen is Trump
loses in 2020 and Democrats simply
renege on the promise and don't move the
embassy and that leads toward more
pressure for Israel to make concessions
to the Palestinians I think that you
have to materially make the change
otherwise there's always the possibility
of reversal on that as far as other
moves in the region I think that
President Trump they again writing
material support to Iranian protesters
would be a solid move I think and I hope
that there's coordination between the
Saudis and the Israelis and the
Jordanians and the Egyptians about
whatever military option needs to be
taken with regards to stopping the
Iranian nuclear program from moving
forward and as we talked the Israeli
government they're working on a bill
that could make it a lot easier for the
death penalty to be enacted on convicted
terrorists there has been vocal
opposition even from within Israel's
intelligence community about how this
legislation would impact the impact of
it what do you say about the death
penalty bill here in Israel I think that
penalty bill should absolutely pass and
I think that they should apply the death
penalty as frequently as possible
against murderous terrorists who leave
the blood of children outside Spyros
restaurants the idea that that Israel
allows these people to languish in
prison just so that the the Palestinian
terrorists can Hamas can take prisoners
I can can go capture an Israeli soldier
and then try and swap them out for
terrorists it's it's bad policy it's
foolish then before you mentioned Iran I
want to go back to that point do you
think the president is doing enough I
mean he tweeted support for the
protesters he didn't scrap the nuclear
deal do you think he needs to do more on
the ground beyond words at this time
well he should certainly scrap the
nuclear deal entirely he sort of split
the baby he's he's certified the deal
but he didn't scrap the entire deal as
it stands he should just get rid of the
deal entirely the congressman moved to
place new sanctions on the government of
Iran and then whatever covert aid they
can afford to to give to the people of
Iran they should absolutely give to the
protesters in order to with the full
intent of toppling that regime that
regime needs to go then in your view why
did it more American Jews vote for Trump
in 2016 and do you think that will
change in 2020 do you think that trumps
Jerusalem speech and other speeches are
cultivating more support from American
Jewish voters well I mean it depends on
on why people vote I don't think that a
lot of American Jews vote based
specifically on Israel I think most
American Jews are irreligious and don't
care particularly much about Israel or
at least they care less about Israel
than they do about abortion or same-sex
marriage for example so yeah laying it
all at the feet of Trump's Israel policy
I think would be foolhardy also Trump
happens to be a particularly toxic
persona and his associations until late
with people like Steve Annan who was who
was friendly toward the alt-right had
driven a lot of Jews away from
I think that this association will help
Trump I think that Trump's particular
toxicity does not play well in sort of
the the white-collar Jewish communities
and places in major cities around the
country that said I think that it's
Israel policy is obviously going to be a
draw for the Orthodox Jewish proportion
of the United States I think people
Orthodox Jews would vote very heavily
for president Trump as indeed they did
in the last election cycle but I think
they'd vote in even bigger numbers now
that that Trump has made clear his
positions on Israel which were really
not all that clear before the election
so what do you make about the close
relationship perhaps even on a personal
level between President Donald Trump and
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu the
image of their friendship where does it
send around the world or who Prime
Minister Netanyahu is smart to cultivate
a personal relationship with President
Trump Trump seems to operate very much
on the basis of personal friendship and
personal relationship and warmth sort of
particular political figures so smart
Netanyahu to do that the idea that
they're about they're besties and they
talk all the time I'm not sure that
that's particularly accurate but they
certainly have shared priorities and I
think that Netanyahu knows that and I
think that Trump understands that as
well are two quick questions for you Ben
first what do you make of the latest
round of news involving President Trump
and a man that you know very well Steve
bandid what do you make of the public
fallout between the two I think that
Donald Trump has never made a smarter
move than she not only got rid of Steve
Benin but then to step on him I think
that Steve and richly deserves it was a
negative force inside the administration
is a negative force for the president
and I think that his connections as I've
said before with the alt-right and his
prevent his sort of promulgation of
their message was a huge mistake not
only for the administration but for the
right generally so I'm very pleased that
the presidents of the United States has
realized and and has spoken the truth of
why been saying all along which is that
Steve Bannon as a self-aggrandizing con
man who was only interested in
irrigating power or the perception
they're up to himself all right then
we'll get you out of here and this last
question you made international
headlines two weeks ago for a very
public
Twitter fight with Rosie O'Donnell it
got nasty very quickly but it is the
start of a new year supposed to turn
over a new leaf and all that any message
of goodwill personally for you and Rosie
O'Donnell well I mean the only thing
Teta Rosie O'Donnell is Rosie at least
buy me dinner first I mean my goodness
she's having have being sexually
harassed by Rosie O'Donnell was
definitely not on my list of New Year's
resolution so I would hope that back
home is doing all right Ben Shapiro
joining us thank you so much to our
daily dose